well of course this Sunday is Easter and
all kinds of activities surrounding
Easter have been canceled
Easter Parade Easter egg hunts all kinds
of Easter gatherings at church
everything canceled so I thought maybe I
should talk to the man at the center of
this very special day see how he's doing
Jesus Jesus are you there hey hey what's
up Conan hey Jesus tell us how are you
how are you doing oh man you know just
hanging in there sheltering in place
like everybody else sheltering in place
I don't understand you're the Son of God
well I like to lead by example so I'm
staying home like the rest of you yeah
it just looks like you're in a suburban
home in Glendale oh yeah that's just the
background I pick for this call kind of
it's more relatable than than this
you know that's my normal crib so oh
yeah right that might that might turn
people off I think yeah so Jesus your
big day Easter got canceled how you
handling that well it's not really
canceled I mean I'm I'm still coming
back from the dead I'm just doing it
from home oh I see instead of a Sermon
on the Mount it's gonna be the Sermon on
the couch that's kind of funny yeah
first year my resurrection will be on
zoom' Yeah right write this out I'm
still doing some of my tricks - okay
look at this uh-huh that's great yeah
well at Jesus I got to say it looks like
you have a really positive attitude you
know what Kony you got to stay positive
it's it's not the first time I've
sheltered in place I was buried in a
tomb for three months three months now I
I thought you were buried in a tomb for
three days yeah three days with no
Netflix no video games it felt like
three months hey speaking of games do
you want to play some Skyrim I'm all
hooked up I love to but I got a show to
do can't really yeah can't really do
that right now
curious so a lot of people want to know
how long is this pandemic gonna last oh
man I'd love to tell you but that's
really more my dad's department you know
he he does plagues locusts pandemics I'm
more
like the tambourine guy right well Jesus
you got a lot of people watching right
now any words of encouragement for your
flock yeah sure
hey guys Jesus here I love y'all best
thing you can do right now is just stay
home stay connected with each other
reach out to your friends your apostles
call your virgin moms that's how we'll
get through it and shout out to the
doctors nurses grocery workers and
everyone keeping us safe you're the real
miracle workers yeah well thank you that
was that was lovely
thanks a lot Jesus any time bye everyone
I love you all oh Jesus
before you go maybe a little help here
sure buddy hey fantastic you'll enjoy
that it's a merlot Oh kind of prefer a
Pinot dude drink that and like it yeah
yeah thank you